i'm just very curious about how you
transitioned from being a
baseball journalist to working in the
jfe industry i mean that that's that's
kind of that's quite a career change
that's a bit of a jump i think that's a
standard promotion
as far as i remember i mean i mean i i i
changed from working at the bbc
to doing youtube i thought that was a
big career shift but that's nothing
compared to you i think
yeah i mean i've always loved writing so
like
i still do uh actually my physical book
is coming out your memoirs right no
necessary memory is about
i think as a reporter like a report of
jv industry
everything about me it's not necessarily
exposed but
you can look and actually learn how much
i made during this year
oh
yeah nobody can explode that much like
it but it's about me so
i guess it's okay that was a flawless
transition to an ad by the way
that sounds like a netflix documentary
behind the mosaic
that's such a good title that'll be a
good title for the book but yeah
i want to say because i think uh i
watched joey's video yesterday before we
uh did this i think i think he asked
something similar but uh
i think we really want to know like how
did you like did you know someone that
was in the industry was like a
craigslist ad that you were like oh
porn actress needed like how did you
like find your way into actually i
tried to have an interesting part-time
job because
i was like became teacher
from a reporter i got more free time so
i have a decent schedule like right at
the reporter like
it's like 24 7. but as a
teacher like you have classes and that's
it so right okay i'm gonna have an
interesting first-time job because you
were that
we had a photo shoot but you know the
dvd came out like i should just sleep
before parents find out i wasn't
teaching any young kids
so you started out doing photo shoots
first or was it oh yeah like it was a
gradual because like
if it comes out soon then maybe people
your friend is going to find out soon
oh so will you like so so how did you
even get the offer to do the
photo shoot so i was just looking for
interesting part-time job because my
friend
actually told me who was working at this
pr company the gaming pr company yeah
yes
and she said i have this personal job
where i just jump in it's nothing sexual
don't expect him just when your friend
says i have this jaw
like it's like oh gosh outside
yeah yeah they got a mixer and we said
goku
in japanese right oh yeah and sometimes
they don't have enough course so like i
fill in and i just pretend i'm one of
them
right right she doesn't know anyone yeah
at the party
but like she just pretend like she's one
of them
a friend of them right so to explain
what a mixer is it's kind of like a
kind of like a group dating session but
not really kind of thing it's like group
speed dating
yeah yeah yeah oh wow weird yeah it's
really strange
yeah it's basically just like it's like
three three guys usually it's like three
guys three girls
right even numbers oh wait i have heard
of this number and
it's like okay i'm gonna the girls just
like
chat up all the boys see which one's
good the boys chat up all the girls see
which ones i'm too competitive
and then they just and then they're just
like okay i'm gonna take her i'm gonna
take him i'm gonna take her kind of
thing yeah yeah
it's really weird i've never done it i
don't know i've never done it either
that sounds like a lot of pressure it's
like something you would do
yeah i i know no i couldn't do that
because i think i'd be like what do you
mean all three if you didn't pick me
i'm joking
in everyone else's mind it's just a
social gathering to you it's like how do
i gamify this how do i win
you've lost you've lost i need to win
this
it's like bro chill come on we're just
trying to chat like chelsea i just
turned everything into the olympics
like i'm like that guy who's like oh
it's a competition oh okay
game on yeah oh my god okay so you did
that job
no like uh my friend did that job i
thought you were probably interesting
you know
pretending to be someone else right all
right right so i'm going to do something
more interesting and like what did you
do on purpose to one up your friend
you're like turning it into a
competition oh my god i always want
something to write about
okay okay that makes sense yeah out of
my experience not like
trying to like i don't know sneak into
somebody's room and try to get
information out of somebody but more
like i want to talk about myself so that
i don't really have to hurt anyone yeah
so yeah uh there was a
part-time job called trying out
well in japanese it was called
adult good monitor
monitor yeah okay i don't know if you
guys use the same monitor it's just the
testing i doubt goods
oh so that monitor in japanese
so you were like a game tester before
adult toys
basically no i applied for that job but
then
yeah hey those companies who let's say
like we're looking for girls
for people for adult good monitor right
these companies are always
jb management company but they try to
lure them in
oh that was like the fishing hook
if you're interested in that then maybe
you get more money
and then you're like oh it sounds good
and i was like i'm gonna i don't think
that i would get
higher like i wasn't that young you know
many
jb actually sell themselves that's 18 or
19.
but they're actually like yeah not
underage
20 but they sell themselves as like
young
young children of course so i was like
like maybe it could be interesting like
i should just
see how many offers i'm gonna get right
okay
and then i got offers like decent offer
right then it was just it couldn't get
out anymore
and then it just opened the floodgates
and then you were in and then it's like
a rage shadow legend sponsorship
they just they throw too much money
again man lately things are
more legal and okay you know but during
that yeah it was more sketchy definitely
okay right yeah they were like that's
really interesting actually just
i didn't realize that they like hired
people like that because it's
yeah because i've always wondered like
how like even in like the us as well
it's like
how do they do it like i'm sure in the
u.s it's probably like a craigslist
but i guess in japan it's not really
like that because i don't see that i
don't
imagine like flipping through like a
like a you know a part-time job magazine
like oh okay i don't think it's a
craigslist i think you're gonna get like
you could have done a ton of tests done
before you can even do anything yeah
yeah so i think yeah there's a lot of
that
yeah there's always another way but i
wrote that everything
in my book
in english i don't really have to keep
it secret
i mean there are people called scout man
scouting right right so if you know
at least one scout and he's going to
lead you to one management company
okay it's not it's kind of like agencies
but we never work individually in japan
i guess in the state
there are more like free agents yeah